[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in rick stroud who covers
the buccaneers for the tampa bay times
unlike anybody else does he also hosts a
sports day tampa bay podcast
uh before we talk about tonight rick
with the buccaneers go back to
when they were what seven and five
we had three losses in four games
what was happening then and then what
happened after that that changed the
buccaneer season
well i think what was happening was
sheer panic um at that point but you
know
it was a situation where tom brady
got with bruce herrions they were
supposed to play golf the league
wouldn't let him uh they had sort of
some long telephone conversations uh i
think without byron left which and
basically
tom said hey here's what i need i i need
more play action i need more
um you know motion pre-snap motion we
got to run the ball more we got to be
more committed to this and i think it
sort of evolved the offense a little
quicker
uh towards the second half and they were
a tired football team you know they had
played a lot of games they played you
know a couple of three-point losses to
the rams and the chiefs and they really
just felt like they needed that break
and and they came back and they they
caught fire
yeah but i i mean it was it's
interesting that teams always have these
moments where there's a dip you know
some point in this season and then then
they start to figure it out later in the
season those teams that are
caught fire they have momentum going
into the postseason how confident were
you though in the last month of the
season if i would have said hey this
team's going to win the super bowl
i think after they got on a run um you
know just talking to the coaches and
watching them they really felt like they
were getting better each week the
schedule got a little easier um you know
they came out i think they were down 17
points to the falcons and it was really
dark and gloomy but brady came back and
i think he threw five touchdown passes
that day and you know they just they
they just felt like the more time they
were together i think people
underestimate you know what kovid and
and tom changing you know systems and
not knowing the plays and he's trying to
memorize plays on the way on the bus to
new orleans you know and so there was a
big learning curve there
and i just think they got better you
know as they as they played
also brady played the season with a
partially torn mco how did they hide
that
that's a good question man i wish i had
the answers to all these uh i'm not sure
i know that tom uh just told them he was
fine i guess he got a physical after he
you know signed his contract when he was
in new york but
um you know basically it was him and
alex guerrero spending you know 12 14
hours a day trying to stabilize that
knee
he said sometimes he'd go to go to bed
with with it all taped up and things
like that um so you know they gave him a
lot of a lot of time off the second half
of the year he took some days
and and he and he got through it you
know he didn't make a big deal out of it
but do you think bruce arians
knew that tom brady had a knee that
needed surgery
i think he knew that he had a problem
yeah i mean i don't know i don't know to
what extent look he was never on an
injury report we can get into that but i
think
i think at the end of the day he was
never going to not play with it right he
started with this same knee that he
finished the season with it wasn't
something that was going to keep him out
of the game
and and you know it's sort of like
don't ask don't tell you know they he i
don't think they wanted to know what was
wrong with that but he had worn a brace
for 13 years so he was still wearing one
also when you sit down with brady and
and you come to the covid
topic
and
i i was curious how surprised you were
that tom answered it uh honestly that
that he had had covid and maybe got it
when they had the uh super bowl armada
yeah well you know you never asked a
question you don't have an answer to dan
that's the key and i i sort of waited uh
we're running out of time because he
gave me 14 of the best minutes of my
life so i uh you know i had to ask at
the end there as we were leaving and he
just you know he was just wanted to move
on i think he said yeah you know i had
it and um they you know a lot of people
got sick i think at the boat parade uh
not just the you know not just the
avocado tequila and stuff but i think he
just he felt like
it's in his past and he just said i'm
worried he turned you know blocked in
bridge and said i'm worried about this
year because
i think we're going to have a lot more
problems with everything that's opened
up and even though guys are vaccinated
they're still going to get sick and you
know we could have players missing games
and before they went to houston um they
had two you know defensive tackles and
on sue being one of them they couldn't
play in the preseason game so you know
that's kind of what he's thinking about
is uh how this can affect them going
forward
it sounds strange to say but is this
super bowl or bust
with tom brady with the buccaneers yeah
well yeah i mean what's a good season
when you have this guy right i mean it
hasn't been done um you know since he
did it 17 years ago but that's why
they're playing and i don't think he's
going to let them let off the gas i mean
there's you know a lot of talk about
complacency and things like this i mean
it's incredible dan i mean when you see
what this guy is able to do he told me
his arm feels like he's 24 he's playing
his 300th
game today 300 start or 300 game and and
that sets up nicely because uh i think
his 400th game will be against arch
manning who will be going
so
you know i just there's no slowdown in
this guy i'm telling you if he feels
healthy and i've talked to alex grow
about this i think he's going to go
beyond just this season and next season
it would not surprise me at all if
that's the case yeah i know i saw the
quote from your uh your column where he
said i feel like i'm 24. usually that
that leaves you you know when you ask a
quarterback what's the first thing that
leaves you they might talk about some
sharpness uh they might talk about you
know usually it's arm strength there
is brady throwing like he's 24
well i wasn't there when he was 24 i saw
him in a lot of super bowls and and
everybody on that staff says he's
throwing the ball as well as they can
ever detect that he did on film um you
know so i mean he's a guy and we talked
about this that he he grew up and he
always had elbow problems in in baseball
playing as a kid he had elbow problems
in michigan and that's how he got with
alex guerrero because they were going to
high arm at one point in new england
went out there to california he was
working with willie mcginnis then he
just says that you know he's never had
any problems since then um so his arm
has been great and you know the way he
takes care of himself with tb12 he's got
34 guys on this roster going to tb12
which is a mile from the facility uh
getting worked on by body coaches each
week so it's you know you might have a
bunch of buccaneers playing until
they're in their 40s now does the team
pick up the tab for that
it's a great question dan you'll have to
read the stories about that i don't you
know i don't want to disclose everything
just yet but
i think the players do i actually think
that it's it's on the players i think i
know this in new england they did
yeah
although i don't think bill liked that
no apparently not that changed pretty
quickly by the way i know that you went
through some lean years down there but
uh you know you you've got it made now i
mean come on
that's it's great to be in tampa
it's tampa bay yeah
it is we got the hockey team yo it's
this is a big night i mean after they
won super bowl 37 to tell you how things
go in tampa their greatest moment right
they win 0-2 super bowl
and then we're at the owners meetings
and they find out they've got to open at
philly they're the only super bowl team
before or since it's
opened on the road and that just fed
right into john gruden's paranoia and
we're at the owner's meeting he's like
i'll tell you what man
i'm around here singing why eagles why
you know what i mean what are we gonna
so yeah it was
so this is a this is a big deal this is
a really big deal that is well done uh
are you surprised at all with what's
happening or not happening with the
raiders with john gruden
not surprised love john is a football
coach he's a terrible gm he's got mike
mayok who's probably not getting to pull
the strings and
i think john will stay and make a go and
they'll bring in bruce allen i mean
that's that's what he does so
terrific play caller great motivator
likes the quarterback he doesn't have uh
you know i can go on and on but i'm not
surprised at all
have fun tonight we'll be checking back
in with you always great to talk to you
rick
good talk to you dan thanks that's rick
stroud he's done a great job covering
the buccaneers tampa bay times